I was in a virtual meeting yesterday and
this dude would not stop making eye
contact with me it was creepy but also
fake he used nvidia's new eye contact AI
I was reading up about it on CNET then
found out that chat GPT replaced human
authors there months ago and nobody even
noticed this made me depressed so I
cuddled my mofflin artificial pet to get
some fake emotional gratification I then
went to my local Art Gallery but I only
found artificial art generated by
mid-journey like this Bob Ross piece
minus the happy little accidents when I
got back to my sleeping pod I was hungry
so I pushed a button to generate some
nutrient paste formulated for my body
based on biofeedback from my neural link
finally I settled down with my VR
headset to watch Mission Impossible 23
But realize Tom Cruise actually died 42
years ago and we just keep deepaking him
thanks to face swap on GitHub